[Music]
i am now
in my third week of me and my wife being
separated for the second time i wasn't
sticking to
the aaa meetings that she asked me to do
normally
it's not the alcohol it's the person you
become when you drink
what's up this is john with dr john
dolone's show
so glad that you're with us and i god i
don't know why i'm yelling it's a pretty
normal chill day um it's happy to see
you that's what it is i'm happy to see
you happy to be talking with you hope
you're doing well if you want to be on
the show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 that's 1-844-683-3291
or go to
johndaloni.com
ask a-s-k
there's a family out here watching we
don't we won't put you on the screen
just in case
you called in sick to work today man
which is cool but
every time there's families that come
watch us it's one of my favorite things
because we always end up talking about
sex or parenting or something that the
whole family just staring at the floor
or looking at each other
or looking at their mom and dad their
side eye and mom and dad are definitely
looking at kids side eye the whole
thing's great so i can't wait to do the
show
and watch you all at the same time
that's going to be fun for me it's going
to be great
um
and a minute ago okay so you what you
guys get when it comes to
um a finished product is not at all like
i'm just not that good
and you're like well i don't think
you're good anyway agreed but you don't
see what it really looks like before
sarah the editing guru back there gets
on it and
i don't know why i used to say diarrhea
a lot and i don't because
kelly would just
bow her head in sadness
and
so the word there's okay this is how it
works
my head's talking and the words i'm
gonna say to a given situation head out
the building
and then there's a filter that says you
can't say that in public
um or it says like uh your grandmother
will come back from the grave and haunt
you if those words leave your mouth and
so there's just like a stockpile of
words over here on the side that
automatically just insert themselves and
i don't know how those words get there
um but
for some reason when something drives me
crazy
i don't i've never had i don't think i
don't think so i don't think you would
know do you know if you have hemorrhoids
i don't think i've had them anyway i'm
looking at the booth and they're all
everyone's putting their head down like
you know we're going to talk about
hemorrhoids together and there's the
family area
but
i like when something drives me crazy i
start to say something that's
inappropriate and then it just comes out
that just gives me hemorrhoids
and so right before the show i was
talking we're talking about a segment
that sarah has edited that's ho she's
just a master at making me look coherent
which
again you're getting that product that's
finished right you should see it
beforehand
and i just said you were like you were
this show's preparation h
and i meant that as a great compliment
it did not
it's not a compliment the way i said it
so i'm gonna retract that you're not
preparation h you're an extraordinary
editor and i'm glad that you're in our
gang is that a better way to say that
there you go way to go everybody listen
just as this is a a
friendly tip from john to you from me to
you
if somebody in your life does something
great and you turn to compliment them
and your compliment is gonna be
you are an anti-itch cream
come up with a different come up with a
different um come up with a different
um way to honor somebody
and for sure i'm getting sarah's shirt
that just says i am preparation h and i
just want her to explain that to her
neighborhood all right let's go to
lauren in salt lake city no more talking
about hemorrhoids what's up lauren
hey doctor john i'm excited to be
talking to you and hopefully not about
hemorrhoids oh thank god i right when i
said that i looked up to see what the
call was about just because who knows
man on this show who knows all right
good great i am not qualified to talk
about hemorrhoids how about that so
what's up
so i'm wondering
in a really busy season of life
how do i figure out which
mental health and relationship practices
and habits i should
prioritize and which ones i should
temporarily let go of a little bit
that's a great question so tell me some
more about that what season of life are
you
in a few things i'm studying for the bar
oh my gosh hey stop right there stop
right there nothing everything else goes
away it goes away that's hard how how
far when you take the exam is it about a
month away
yeah it's the end of july so like six
weeks away okay so when we're when this
episode comes out it'll be right before
you take the bar
um right okay so i've had a ringside
seat to that
that's a lot what else
um i have we have two children one of
them is two years old one of them two
months old oh my what are you doing what
are you doing that's fantastic okay so
you got two
maniacs it's a great time to be studying
for the bar what else
yeah
um that's pretty much it my husband
works full-time um
i'm dealing with some
symptoms of postpartum depression
and
a lot of my a lot of the things that
like my therapist and my midwife
recommend are similar things to what you
recommend on this show like
making time for yourself getting
exercise getting sleep
all those good things but i feel like
i'm not giving myself a fair shot
because i just don't
have time to do every single
one and i need to figure out like which
ones are most important gotcha okay i
love love love this question
um here are three i'm gonna
i'm rattling these things off but here
are three things that guide that choice
for me okay and i'll walk you through
each of them and then we can get real
specific about your situation
the first one is
data
and i didn't believe this but the truth
is
what you want to improve or what you
want to change you got to measure it
and for instance i'm using my friend dr
lane norton's carbon app c-a-r-b-o-n i
get i have no affiliation with it i've
got no nothing with it other than
it's a app to help you lose weight
app to help you gain control over your
food
and it's incredible because i thought i
was super attuned to my body i thought i
was super attuned to what my body needed
turns out i was off by about 1500
calories a day i just was way off and i
was wrong and i only know that because
of data i wore um one of those uh heart
rate variability devices for a while it
was great for me i'd wake up and be like
dude i crushed it last night a great
night of sleep and it would say hey you
need to go back to bed do not work out
today and other days i woke up thinking
man i'm overwhelmed and it would say hey
your body is primed ready to rock and
roll go run 10 miles
and so data is really important
sometimes if you don't have devices data
can be just as simple as
getting a note card and writing down
here's the things i want to get done
today here's things i need to get done
today
and just checking them off
am i doing the things that i need to get
done today okay so that's number one
number two is other people
and it sounds like that's one that is
important for you
i am a terrible judge of my own
emotional state sometimes
i can feel like i'm in a great mood and
my wife will tell me hey you're not okay
and you're heading into a season that
i've seen before how can i how what do
you need from me in this season because
i see where we're going and
i don't like that when my buddies call
me i'm like hey man we've checked out a
couple of things or we're i'm worried
about you like those things drive me
crazy but also it's a great data point
that i don't have then the third one is
over time listening to my body
and not trying to fight myself all the
time what i mean by that is there's some
days i just need to sleep
yesterday i had a big workout planned
and i woke up and i've been on the road
and before that i was on the road and
before that was on the road and what i
needed a lot yesterday was two more
hours of sleep so i stayed in bed and i
have to deal with the shame of that and
the you loser and whatever and
instagram's gonna say groin dude all
that stuff but i need to sleep and i
ended up having a much much better day
you see what i'm saying there so those
are the three things that that that
get me through that help me
decide which which things i need to be
doing whether it's resting whether it's
meditating whether it's getting with
people and hanging out with people
whether it's eating better whether
whatever the thing is exercising
so
i tell you all that to tell you this
your body does not do a good job of
differentiating between physical stress
and psychological stress
that's why
hard-charging ceos will work 14-hour
days and then they want to run a
marathon on top of that and they just
drop dead
or their
physiological age is 65 and their
physical age like their birthday is
they're only 42 years old
and so what i would tell you is you are
in
two of the most stressful situations a
human being can put themselves in other
than a wartime or like a police officer
getting shot at
and you're doing them all at the same
time and that is having two kids two or
under and taking the bar do you
recognize how hard that is
i think so
i think you do intellectually i don't
think you fully
wrapped your head around
how
stressed your body actually is tell me
i'm crazy
i don't think you're crazy okay my guess
is you are a great law student and you
are looking around at all of your
classmates taking this exam
and so you just think okay we'll just
keep walking and you've got two little
kids and you've got some friends who are
parents of young kid anyway
you're just taking the next step in the
next step
i need you to
just acknowledge
just for a minute
you are under
extraordinary stress
cool
yeah i think that's fair
and you said something that i want to
lean into
and that is this
your husband's working full-time is he
available to help out are you having to
do all this by yourself
i mean
other than like
being at work eight to five he's great i
mean the minute he gets home he's like
either playing with the kids or cleaning
like he doesn't really have much time to
himself okay himself either because he's
like picking up all the
things that i'm not doing okay so
here's what i would suggest
exercise is gonna look different from
you for you right now i'm going to tell
you it's really important that you move
your body
i'm going to tell you it's really
important for you to get outside if you
at all can
but i'm also going to tell you don't go
running don't go run 10 miles
i think you should walk a lot
if you're gonna lift weights do it for
20 minutes and do it light okay get out
and move your body you don't need to add
quote unquote more stress what exercise
what you want that to do right now is to
help cycle through those stress hormones
that are pumping through your body right
now because your body knows if you gotta
pass the bar you gotta pass the bar you
gotta pass the bar and your body knows
got two little kids got two little kids
right you see what i'm saying and so i
want exercise to be something that um
helps
sleep is just gonna be hard to come by
where i see new moms get buried with the
sleep issue is they get anxious and
stressed out about how little sleep
they're getting
you see what i'm saying because i'm
supposed to get nine i'm supposed to get
eight hours supposed to get seven hours
supposed to get eight hours and that
stress is on top of the fact that
they're only getting sleep every two
hours right
and so i'd give yourself a break on i'm
just in a funky season right now where
i've got a two-month-old and a
two-year-old
and
i heard this advice with with my friend
uh cassie and she's brilliant at helping
students pass the bar
and her slogan was this
let it suck once
is that does that ring a bell with you
yeah yeah i just
i don't know i just want
i feel bad because i feel like i've been
saying that the whole time
i've been in law school and i just i
want my
relationships with my kids my husband to
survive this season they will they will
you're at the finish line
all right i'm asking you this with all
sincerity are you gonna pass the bar
yeah okay i think you are too
and what that means is there's a finish
line coming up here in about 30 days or
45 days
here's what would be a great thing for
you is to sit down with your husband and
that y'all can do it tonight after you
get the the little ones to bed
sit down with your husband and say all
right we got 45 days to go
here's what i need
and i need the next 45 days to be all
about me and look at him and say you
have been
unbelievable
through all of this
we got 45 more days to go and you're
going to get your wife back
actually let's do 50 days because you're
gonna you're gonna need a break too hope
you'll have a vacation or something
playing on the back end of this thing
which by the way won't be a vacation
because you have a three month old at
that point right and so
you're gonna do the best we can maybe uh
parents can come in whatever
but i want you to map out here's what i
need i need help with meals
i need help with bedtime all those
things that he does but i want it down
on paper so that your body can relax
okay
and if you have to call in some
reinforcements if you have to hire
somebody to help out for the next 30 45
days as you get through this last kick
at the end
do that okay spend the money that even
if you don't spend the money figure it
out
and
cut your streaming service whatever the
thing is
cut back if at all possible get some
help even if it's hi
there's a couple of times my son got
hired um
to just go play with little kids while
mom or dad was at home right so it was
like an in-house babysitter kind of
thing but it was just basically a
distraction
um so that mom or dad could work from
home and it worked out great for
everybody my son made like five bucks
and the kids got to play with a little
bit older kid and mom and dad got the
time they needed to separate out but
this isn't the moment to redesign your
whole wellness plan
you're 45 days out from a major
milestone
and you're in the middle of chaos with a
two two year old and a two month old
this is a moment though to say this is
what i need
you gotta move your body
you gotta eat as good as you can
you got to
get some sleep where you possibly can
and if your husband can wake up in the
middle of the night and help out there's
45 days to the finish line you getting
some sleep would be incredible if at all
possible may not be impossible
breastfeeding it may be impossible
you gotta have some sort of relationship
connection even if that's sitting by on
the couch and your husband is holding
your hand and holding the back of your
neck to say hey we're gonna do that for
30 minutes then we're gonna go to bed
whatever that looks like for y'all
then in 45 days we're gonna circle back
to data
other people
and listen to your body and then we're
going to be intentional about what do we
need moving forward what world are we
going to create post bar when i'm a
lawyer when you're working eight to five
we've got two little kids what world do
we want to create in two years and five
years and seven years and let's reverse
engineer that and start working on that
right now
but all that to say pass that bar exam
have it suck one time
don't have to take it again because you
gotta do this whole test prep over again
connect with those babies and tell your
husband exactly what you need over the
next 45 days
we're rooting for you email me back and
let me know when you pass okay we'll be
right back
john delonay here all right people
you're adults so i'm gonna talk to you
like adults and it's going to be hard
for some of you to hear you ready
it's time to move on from the grandma
hand-me-down facebook marketplace deal
or the just plain old nasty junky
mattress it's ridiculous we upgrade our
smartphones every three months but we
hang on to the same uncomfortable lumpy
mattress for decades your sleep is too
important for that it's time to invest
in a good night's sleep with a high
quality mattress and for me that's dream
cloud i'm speaking from experience when
i say this is the easiest thing you can
do to start improving your life and your
health and dream cloud is making it even
easier with an offer exclusively for my
listeners
499 dollars in accessories plus an
additional 250 discount that's 749 in
accessories and savings and you'll get
pillows a mattress protector and luxury
sheets it's time to change your sleep
and your life visit
dreamcloudsleep.com or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get your new mattress today
and get 749
in savings
all right we're back let's go to jenny
from the block in serotonin
saratoga springs what's up jenny
hi dr d how are you
i'm good how are you doing we are
rocking it on man what's up
um so i guess the short of it is
my
my grandparents live next door
and they
moved somebody into their backyard
who like in a camper in their backyard
who has an addiction problem
and
i
need help
figuring out how to protect my family in
that
whole situation
because not like
i don't have a problem
with people who have addictions
obviously like that's a whole other
jenny why do you hate america i'm just
kidding i'm just
i'm piling onto your own shame that
you're yeah take that off um clearly
you've identified a safety issue okay
doesn't mean that you guys that you hate
people that are having they're
struggling with addiction that means
that you're trying to keep your family
safe
um
so what what what about the situation
makes you feel
unsafe um
well
this person
stabbed someone
that's it
and
now he's living in my backyard oh
there's that
jeez talk about overly sensitive jenny
um yeah
so
what's what's the addiction
heroin
so
uh i have been accused of being overly
compassionate and i've been accused of
being full of leftist propaganda because
my default setting is to love people and
to welcome them into my house rather
than kick them out
i totally get that and 100
i would not be okay
if a violent heroin addict moved into my
grandparents house next door to me in a
camper
yeah i got little kids do you all have
kids exactly where i'm at
i have a three-year-old yes okay so what
is the connection between your
grandparents and this this
um this
backyard resident
um he is
the grandchild of their friends
and his so
his grandparents passed away so i think
that they feel like they owe it to his
grandparents to like take care of him
okay
all right so
this situation is one of those that's
most of us will not have um
stabbing heroin addicts living next door
to us
particularly in our grandparents
backyard in a camper but this is one of
those
outside the bell curve situations that
we all deal with
especially when it comes to family and
that is
setting up boundaries that are that are
pretty firm
and so
i think it's you and your husband
sitting down and is is dad in the
picture
i just assume that i shouldn't do that
okay dad's in the picture is y'all
sitting down and saying
um
where are our boundaries here and
boundaries may be as long as that person
is living next door
us and our kids will not go to my
grandparents house
we refuse to go over there
um if this person is somebody you can
have a conversation with it might be
saying hey
um
we understand that you're living here
for a season in my grandparents backyard
um
it's not okay for you to come over to
our house or maybe you wait until that
person does try to come over to your
house and say hey this is private
property we'd prefer if you don't come
on to our house is that a conversation
awkward absolutely is it hard and ugly
and messy absolutely
might your grandparents revolt and say
well then forget you i'm going to leave
our house and all my money to this this
guy in the back maybe
but it comes down to a safety
conversation that you and your husband
feel safe you could also get together
your husband and say hey we're gonna go
knock on this person's door and invite
them out to coffee around our fire pit
and say
ask them what's been going on in their
life and if there's you all can decide
what that is right but if you all get on
the same page and then
there's the hard part communicating that
to your grandparents with respect and
dignity not just lobbying grenades right
have you talked to them
yes i um i went over there and i said i
was talking my grandfather is like
ninety percent deaf in one ear and he
can't hear any other one so he was
watching the race with his head set on
so he couldn't hear me and i was talking
to my grandmother which is an easier
conversation
and so i was like hey grandma like do we
have a timeline on how long this guy is
going to be living out back um and she
was like no i don't really think he does
either
and i was like oh that's
you know
like what are we going to do about that
if that turns into a problem well it
turns out it is like it will turn into
forever
yeah that's what i'm afraid of and she
said um that's the thing about because
we just bought my parents house that was
my parents house and we just bought it
okay um
and so
she said that's the thing about home
ownership you have to learn to live with
your neighbors
and i just dude bit my tongue on that
one that's a great grandma line right
there that's like grandma burn right
there that's awesome
oh dude that's awesome good job for your
grandma so here's here's grandma just
put her boundary down this person is
living here you need to suck it up and
get over it
that's not what you want to hear but
that's what you got and so she actually
is right you all get to decide what
happens next are we going to sell mom
and dad's house at full market value and
head out because we don't want our kids
living here are we going to wait until
there's a problem are we going to
address it head-on you all get to decide
what comes next just recognize that what
comes next is going to be uncomfortable
there's not really a way around that
and just because it's uncomfortable
doesn't mean it's wrong
okay right
um
if i'm in your situation and you've
already had the conversation with
grandma
probably what i would do is be very
proactive about reaching out
i would go meet the person to the guy
yes
the way you just said unless this person
is scary right or to complain
[Music]
he's just like not all there
so okay i don't know how i don't even
know how that conversation would even
go like i'm knocking on a camper in my
backyard like hey
like that but again you want a beer
i mean yeah
that's probably what i would do quite
honestly but um here's another thing you
might try
is writing your grandparents a letter
because your dad your granddad can read
that he might not hear it but he can
read it
and just say hey i love you
i am nervous as your granddaughter
living next door to somebody who
has a violent history
and who is making me and our little one
feel unsafe
so here's what we're going to do until
then
you all are welcome to come to our house
if you'd like to
but we just don't feel safe right now
and if you're going to choose to have
this person live in your backyard over
us that's great that's your home
and write it down because two things
happen when you write something down
like that number one it helps you you
have to clarify it here's what my actual
problem is and we tend to be like that
guy's a
that guy's a
conservative i ain't talking to that
well what is the actual problem with the
politic right what are the things that
are driving you it makes you identify it
and then the second thing is it gives
the reader an opportunity to read it
have their body respond to it they're
going to get angry they're going to get
self-righteous and whatever and they can
go back to it and they can go back to it
and then go back to it and
then they can be like actually we're
choosing this over this and at least we
can have a conversation about it right
so that would be my recommendation write
a letter to your grandparents and then
move on
the more you pull into your driveway and
look over the fence and get raged out
and hate and all that
you are gonna choose to make your life
miserable
and the more you drive and look and
you're always scared and
your child is gonna pick up on that that
three-year-old's gonna pick up on that
and they're gonna think there's
something scary and unsafe about mom and
about our house and
you're just gonna create a cascade there
so
um
yeah you're in a messy situation i'm
sorry it's hard
um but your grandma's right your
grandma's right
i guess they're allowed to let somebody
live in their backyard with a camper
depending on your deed restrictions or
wherever you all live
and you all have to now make some
choices about what y'all's life is going
to look like or what life's going to
look like moving forward i hate y'all
got put in that situation
um
man i hate that their compassion
is
may end up costing them their house it
makes me hard to evict somebody down the
road all those things
sounds like a mess and
to be clear have some good boundaries
and uh holler back
something goes sideways i'd love to hear
about it we'll be right back
hey what's up delona here i've got a
word from our sponsor betterhelp i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done it's that deep
feeling of exhaustion after a long
period of being overworked and
overstressed and just fried and most of
us associate burnout with work but
burnout can happen at any area of our
lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at betterhelp betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your healing betterhelp is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with you and your therapist you never
have to even see anyone on camera if you
don't want to it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours and today our listeners get 10 off
their first month at
betterhelp.com that's betterhelphelp.com
all right we are back let's go to ryan
man all the way to fairbanks alaska
what's up ryan
hey john how are you doing i'm good man
how's uh how's things
uh they've been better but i can't
complain too much i'm pretty blessed
so tell me what's going on man how can i
help
so
i am now
in my third week of me and my wife being
separated for the second time
i guess
where my mind is going on this is i'm
starting to feel
a disconnect kind of like my body's
telling me or preparing me for
more trauma and i'm just in this mindset
of what where do i go from here i i do
want to save this marriage but i'm at
the same time i'm just
starting to feel disconnected and i'm
kind of lost here man yeah dude so what
happened man why are y'all separated
again
well this time um
you want me to tell you the first time
or we just want to stick to this one for
now run me through the first one in 30
seconds or less and then give me the
second one
all right first time um came back from
afghanistan 2012 became an alcoholic or
a weakened alcoholic and eight years
later of being an alcoholic
she finally kicked me out okay um
second time i served up for october 24th
2020 so i've been server since then
um congrats this time
i appreciate it um this time is
i didn't
have it all together financially and i
wasn't sticking to
the aaa meetings that she asked me to do
yeah
and there's a lot that goes behind that
but
so
normally
it's not the alcohol
normally it's the person the person
it's the person you become when you're
drinking
so who are you when you drink
uh disconnected um
emotionally absent
i
didn't
give her anything that she needed in a
marriage when i was drinking i was just
separate
like roommates go to bed late never
never present
so you weren't you're not violent you're
not rageful
no sir okay so instead of big outbursts
you just slowly over the course of a
decade
um
she just
she just slowly was drowning right
right in isolation she said what was it
what was there some big event or she
finally just had enough in
20. she has stuck around and really
supported me through the last eight
years and i think she just had enough
you know enough's enough yeah and
it was unhealthy and it was time to make
a change so what brought you back
together
well i believe sobriety had a big play
in that i you know i stayed server for
the last 20 22 months and you picked a
hell of a time to get sober man
congratulations it's been a hard season
dude
you can get through this season wow
um
when you got sober
did you heal or did you trade
here's what i mean by that
you come back from afghanistan
you experience some stuff you saw some
stuff drinking helps that
mute that alarm system right it works
and you can go work during the week and
stay busy and that helps and then you
can collapse in the evening and do the
whole thing up over again
and
then you can go through treatment and
you can go to aaa or whatever get sober
you can stop putting alcohol in your
body
but if you don't go through the process
of healing what your body was trying to
numb out in the first place
then it just moves to something else
and sometimes that something else is
work sometimes that something else is
netflix sometimes that something else is
just staring off into space
did you heal or did you just trade
addictions
i believe
i traded addiction for work yeah i'm
being honest there was something no it's
i appreciate your bravery yeah
yeah i believe i did i work a lot and
there were some other things going on i
was looking down the barrel of the
divorce shotgun there and
and it didn't happen thank god but it
was
there's just a lot of going on and i was
focusing heavily on what she was doing
instead of
what i needed to do to heal that's right
so it sounds like she got back into a
relationship with you because alcohol
was gone and she married the same or she
got back connected with the same person
who showed up and was just unplugged
just instead of
um
sleeping with alcohol now you started
sleeping with your job is that fair yep
okay that's fair
so
the hard question i always ask in this
situation is is
she interested in staying married
um
i don't believe she is yeah that's been
brought up
and the last separation it was brought
up and i was told i would have paperwork
at the end of the next week and that was
2020. so we're looking at 2022. i'm not
sure honestly if she could pull the
trigger any point or not
so what do you want to do man
[Music]
i want personally i want to save the
marriage and
there's a lot here we have five kids
together we have a big family and
i believe we can build something new i
truly do
but i'm trying to get healed myself yeah
at the same time has she told you what
she needs from you
i believe i've heard her say this i want
to say yes but there's i feel like i'm
missing information and we just never
connect on that
level of what do you truly need for me
and not what are you asking for me have
you ever gone to see a marriage
counselor
uh no why not tried
i tried to get her in with one of my
counselors and it didn't go very well
and i do have a i do have a marriage
counselor and a trauma counselor
scheduled for the end of this month okay
so that's on the table
but i mean she just she feels done she
really
doesn't want to be here
so here's here's what you can do right
now
um
you can look at this as a mission to
quote unquote save this marriage
and if you look back over the last 10
years
what you're going to end up doing is
trying to solve a puzzle
that you don't have all the pieces to
and so you're going to end up using a
lot of energy you're going to have a lot
of worry you're going to have a lot of
expense you can do a lot of stuff that
may not get you where you want to go
you have been a
brave man to say the words that when you
look in the mirror and you are honest
most of this challenges you
for any number of reasons it might be
undealt with childhood trauma it might
be stuff you dealt with
on mission it on deployment who knows
what it is
it might be you got home and you got
five kids and you feel like you're
better at work than you are at home and
so we naturally just gonna go where we
do things that were we're better right
i've been there
all that to say is you've landed here
and the common denominator moving
forward is you you haven't told me
anything that she's cheating on you that
she's an addict too that you just said
like no she's just been putting in the
time and putting in the time and finally
she just said i can't i'm out is that
fair yeah i mean there was some
infidelity that caused some trauma on
her part she cheated on you
yes okay all right so she's not
blameless in this deal either right
neither one of us are okay all right
so there's two things moving forward man
one is
you coming up with a clear
detailed plan
on how ryan's life is going to be
different
not how your marriage is gonna get saved
not how your wife's and you are gonna
how ryan's life is gonna be different
and the cool thing about that is or the
sucky thing is is you play a role in it
the cool thing is you can work on that
and that might be as simple as i'm gonna
turn the tv off i'm gonna start getting
some sleep i'm gonna start getting some
exercise i'm gonna get a group of guys
together i'm gonna go see a therapist
asap
those are all things that are gonna help
you become a better
husband a better father a better
employee a better man a better citizen
it may be that part of who i want to
become is i want to become solvent
financially i'm going to get out of debt
and stop being an idiot with my money
i'm going to learn new things and then
i'm going to implement these new things
and so it's just a matter of getting on
a plan
right hang on the line and all and i'm
going to put you on a plan for free i'll
pay for it okay
it may be i'm going to get a group of
books and i'm going to get a group of
guys and we're going to start reading
books and i'm going to yeah i want you
to stand alone i'm just in a couple of
books you can read too okay
all these things have one common
denominator and that is you focusing on
you getting well for the first time in a
long time hear what i'm saying yes sir
second thing is this
um you may have heard me say this on the
show it's my favorite marriage metaphor
when you get to these moments
what is in the past
is in the past and there's a period at
the end of that sentence
where most of us who try to fix our
marriages or improve our marriages or
save our marriages and i've been there
is what we try to do is go back to
remember when we didn't have any kids
and how awesome it was we were having
sex all the time and we had money to
spend and we were running around the
country and around the world
and we have that picture in our head and
then we try to superimpose that picture
over five kids infidelity alcoholism and
we try to make that work again
and what we have to do is let that go
and so the analogy is
you could not go down
to
downtown new york
and sweep up all the glass and twisted
steel
and recapture all the natural gas
and re and
get all the dry wall back and rebuild
the twin towers you can't do it that
thing's they fell
there's a period in that sentence as
hard as it is to say out loud
the only thing we can do moving forward
is get some crews in there to excavate
the whole thing
get with an architect or a couple of
architects draw something new what do we
want this thing to look like
get with a set of engineers and some
construction teams to build something
that's arguably more beautiful and
stronger
and build something completely new
that's the only option you have
or just to move on and let it decay
right
so the question for you and your wife is
not hey we want to fix the marriage and
save the it is
i'm interested in building something
completely and totally new
are you in
and that's
the limbo right now is killing you the
limbo right now is killing her and quite
honestly the limbo right now is killing
your kids
and i think it's time for a breakfast
after you detail all the things you're
gonna do and you put the plan down
is to say hey
do you want to build something new
what was it was do you want to build
something new with me because if you do
i'm all in
and if not we need to do the paperwork
now and we need to move on
is that fair
yes sir
as far as those are here it's what i
needed
do you he
were were you in a combat
yes sir okay
you know the difference between
when the siren sound
and that gap before confrontation
that's the worst part right
yep it is that's where you are and
that's where you've been for a while
there is no engagement but you know
something's coming and what may be
coming may be
um
reconnection and revisiting and
rebuilding something magic something
great
or it may be the end it may be
termination
but you're in that gap the sirens are
sounding and they have been for a long
time and there's just no bullets flying
yet and at some point somebody's got to
pull the trigger
and i'm kind of beating this metaphor up
but at some point you got to sit down
and you'll go to ihop down the street or
wherever you go in fairbanks alaska and
say
um i don't know if you get a moose
burger or something i don't know but you
go sit down we have those
of course you do
be incredible somebody listening to this
send me some moose meat man i'm all in
um
but you go sit down and say hey
use that same metaphor i just gave you
we can't you can't go rebuild 911 the
twin towers they fell
are you in to build something new and if
you're not let's call it as hard as that
is let's be adults about this and let's
love and honor these five kids through
this
um or
let's start from ground zero and get the
professionals around us that we need to
build something beautiful are you in on
that i am all right here's what i'm
going to send you to help you get going
either way
i'm going to send you a year's
subscription to ramsey plus
that's my friend dave ramsey he's got
that
financial peace university it's millions
and millions of people have used it to
get out of debt i'm gonna send it to you
also comes with the apps and that
connects to your bank and all the stuff
all the bells and whistles okay
i want you to use that thing and i want
you to watch all the videos on that deal
and if she'll watch him with you that'll
be amazing okay that's number one and
make your kids watch them too why not
number two i'm gonna send you my new
book which is own your past change your
future and what that book is is here's
all the stuff
and now we're at the turning point
here's all the crap
now we have to ask ourselves that one
terrifying question what do we do now
and it is a step by step to walk
yourself out of a wellness plan okay i'm
gonna send you that i'm also gonna send
you a total money makeover which is
dave's book that helps with that okay
and i want you to commit to reading
those books
let your wife know as a part of your
plan moving forward you're gonna read
those books okay so hang on the line
here brother um all right let me just
ask are you all in
i'm all in okay thank you okay
let me know how this conversation goes
and by the way
if she won't have this conversation she
won't have breakfast with you
i want you to sit down at a computer
and type out a long letter to her that
explains all this in it
she may not give you an audience now
hopefully she does hopefully she'll be
an adult and you can be an adult and
y'all can just go have breakfast
together if she won't write it out write
her a letter and say here's where i'm at
here's the things i'm gonna do
here's that picture of the twin towers
and here's what i wanna do moving
forward
we gotta scratch and clear the surface
and build something brand stinking new
you deserve that she deserves that those
five kids deserve that and i'm here to
tell you i've seen it done
it's a lot of work man
[Music]
but i was in new york a few weeks ago
doing media
man and the monument they've built and
the new tower they've built is something
to behold it can be done
y'all are worth it go get it we'll be
right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow
i'm so grateful and one of the things
i've been most excited about hearing is
that this book is not just for people
who are healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past
this book is for everyone in every walk
of life the single 30 year old looking
to sharpen their mind the 25 year old
hoping to make new friends the parent
who's tired of seeing their kids eyes
glued to a screen but who doesn't know
how to re-enter their life people coming
out of abusive relationships
everyone and this book isn't me talking
at you this book is me walking with you
because i've been there too
to better understand and improve your
mental relational and emotional health
please check out own your past change
your future at johndaloni.com today
that's
johndaloney.com today
all right we are back um
i got this email
that i i usually don't respond to these
but
this is one that i wanted to touch on
here here's what the email says
um
it's uh
this is condensed but it says i'd like
to know what depression is this is from
joshua says i'd like to know what
depression is
and he even put depression in quotation
marks
and then wrote is it real he goes on to
say from my experience i see people that
are what i would call sad
and they say they're depressed and use
it as a crutch
oh joshua so
um yes
depression is very
very real
it's a physiological concept it's a
biochemical um
process in the human body depression is
very very
real
um it runs on a spectrum some as the
compression of feelings the chemical and
spiritual stress from holding back
childhood
traumas or neglect
all the way to the deep dark black hole
the inability to move or function
psychosomatic functioning right body
pains etc
it's very very real
and some experience it in in some ways
um
deeper if you will than others
um
the
the dsm which i'm not a fan of but it
does do some good descriptive stuff
basically
depression is
are was your body shutting you down in a
way that
inhibits
normal functioning right
depression lies to us it tells us that
things are always going to be this way
things are your fault and nothing you
can do will change your situation and so
over time your body just begins to
compress down stop
um it can loop on people which makes you
feel helpless i can't even think about
this hopeless this is always going to
happen and then here's the bad one is
the burdensomeness
people would be better if i wasn't here
it begins to distort the way we see and
feel reality depression joshua is more
than just sadness
in response to struggles or setbacks
depression changes your perception in
the way you feel the way you see the
world and experience the world
um bringing you feelings of emptiness
and doom it impacts the way you sleep
the way you work the way you eat the way
you enjoy life or don't enjoy life the
way you don't eat the way you don't work
et cetera
and
yes josh
i've met with countless people
especially when i was working in
university students would come say hey
my i just failed the test and i needed
to pass this test
i my mom just moved out on my dad
um
and they would say i'm just depressed
and i would say you're not depressed
you're sad you're really really sad
and then
in a month
two months three months they circle back
and they say hey i haven't eaten i've
lost 30 pounds
i can't breathe i'm unable to sleep
every moment i wake up i open my eyes i
start counting the minutes so i can
close them again and moving my i feel
like i'm doing life with a weight vest
on
that is an instant i need you to go see
a counselor i absolutely people say
anxiety's never killed anybody right
panic attacks never killed anybody just
gotta ride those you gotta ride that
wave depression does kill people a lot
absolutely it does
so um depression looks different across
gender and across culture um
a lot of men express depression by
pounding their chests and saying look at
me
um it's it's called the one up position
it's just it's a physiological thing
they will they will sometimes bow up
this is a a gender generalization but
women often show depression by one down
right
they
latch to the bottom of a family or
relationship and they put everybody's
needs ahead of their own and they just
ride out as slow as they can
underneath the water
and
both of those are expressing the same
powerlessness feeling there
sometimes it's stomach aches numbing out
back pains irritability frustration and
aggression especially in young kids
a great primer i'm going to point you to
andrew huberman's podcast the hubermann
lab podcast and you can scroll down and
find he's got an incredible biochemical
he gets way into
the neural chemicals and the the um
neurotransmitters and the
neuromodulator all stuff the chemical
process of depression it's about a
two-hour podcast it's incredible if you
want to go down a rabbit hole but to
answer this question
broadly yes depression is very very real
and if you have found yourself in a
situation where you are unable to
function you do not feel or express or
see joy anymore
you are unable to laugh
your body doesn't respond in those you
just have a running low or more
importantly you feel like the world
would be better if you just weren't here
or you want you don't want to die you
just want the pain to stop
because i hurt
please call somebody
and joshua if you know somebody in that
situation friends say something
loved ones get in the middle of that and
say hey
you play a role here you got a purpose
here
i'm gonna call in everybody i can to
keep you alive and to help you heal
depression's for real
it's for real so thanks for the email
man um
here
let me just
i had some notes there i was reading my
notes there about depression this is i
don't have these notes
let's don't get into the into the game
people to diagnose each other or to not
diagnose each other if somebody says
they're struggling then they're
struggling whether it's depression or
sadness who cares
somebody's hurting in your life
lean into that
do you just suck it up and move on man
be wrong on that once and see what hap
what happens
it's not something to be wrong on lean
into them
and say hey
everybody
is helped by moving their body everybody
everybody's helped by having good close
relationships every everybody's helped
by sleep
everybody's helped by having somebody
they can check in with and talk to
everybody's helped by eating well
right
those are all basic things that whether
someone's quote-unquote got sadness or
someone's quote-unquote got depressed so
dude josh don't play armchair
quarterback somebody says hey i'm really
depressed
say have you gonna talk to anybody about
that
lean into that connection don't
disconnect and be like that's not what
that is don't be that guy don't be that
guy
or if somebody comes to you and says hey
i'm really sad because uh somebody i
love passed away or because me and my
wife aren't talking or
don't immediately jump like well it
sounds like you've got major depression
no don't do that either sit with people
and if they need someone to talk to be
that encouraging voice and send them to
talk to somebody
all right that's my that's my thing i
just man armchair
armchair diagnose diagnostics
diagnosticians drive me crazy
armchair diagnosticians drive me crazy
anyway all right so today's this is
kelly's favorite song
in the world actually
um she just brought these lyrics in
during the break in the song by is by
one of her favorite songwriters anderson
east
and i don't know whether to take this
personal or not but the title of the
song is i hate you
and the lyrics go like there's not a
better song for kelly i don't know what
it is
this is kelly's uh expression of her
feelings towards me in her song i hate
you and it goes like this
what did this all start about because
this ain't how it started out you should
have stuck with alcohol but you had to
have that adderall
dang kelly and now you're crying in the
parking lot with heels in your hands
saying i'm the one who's not making any
sense as much as i hate you please don't
ever leave me i won't kelly
don't don't know what i'd do if you ever
followed through you said that we're
over but can we talk when we're sober
because baby i love you baby i love you
i'm married kelly more than i hate you
as much as i hate you
i love you
i love you too
we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode over the
time that we had lived together the
environment that i was living in with
her just became really unsafe what does
that mean one of the roommates
threatened to shoot up drug dealers and
then the drug dealers came back and said
we're going to shoot everyone in your
entire house so sometimes i talk to
folks they're like it's just not safe
there's cheetos everywhere then there's
uh it's not safe because someone's gonna
murder us boyce long-distance
polyamorous boyfriend is now moving in
okay so there are going to be two
boyfriends living in the house we're
terrified our kids are going
to be
molested the idea that because they are
all dating
means they're more likely to sexually
assault and molest a child isn't
accurate